welcome to this video playing creeper
Blanca one of the coolest Nick sup taxi
see vatican city thats it's great our
game let's see we get our Queens gambit
accepted hmm yeah yeah I normally play
that yeah this normal i'm jim i don't
really have a sharp weapon against that
normally playing d takes you five okay
I'm doing that I know it's not terribly
exciting but this is what I have what I
do against this opening let's see p 3
Bishop b2 or 92 95 is also quite often a
good idea activating this piece and
preparing Bishop f3 mmm if i take here
at bishop f3 may be attacking her be 70
you can just ignore that because of the
the back rank I guess very quickly
played okay so if i take here and what
exactly is the problem yeah Bishop c6 i
guess
remarkable so this means i have
absolutely zilch after after Bishop c8
okay maybe i can i can do this and
Bishop b4 or Bishop a5 actually just
controlling d8 this this is in fact
still an idea so we does not mind Knight
b6 interesting okay I take the bishop
out really I don't mind that
yep you know but I have Bishop 85 was
your Bishop a fine i think it's better
just covering the DA term the DA to
scram
yeah black is not very well coordinated
efore here Knight f6 okay probably this
is a good improving move threatening
ok let's take here and now he 490 of six
am taking on d 7 yeah that's obviously
not bad but is it the best continuation
not sure but okay I'm down by about two
minutes if I go Rupe CSE one here what
exactly is a smooth rock paper should be
75 95 okay okay so this means I probably
need to take I can go Bishop d7 and
maybe Bishop c6 cell attacking the porn
now that's not great okay so night g7 do
I have a better move I wonder what his
son okay Bishop Bishop d7 hmm I can
always play a five of course just ER he
needs to go to d5 and then I take it
with the draw but it's that's very very
lame but bishops is six is really a
problem here
yeah Bishop c6 is the problem I'm just
losing the pawn or I need to play you
five on the very unfavorable
circumstances hmm now that's a problem
okay that's very lame e5 but probably
necessary 95 and then now maybe I can
just continue
continuing means not taking on d5 which
would secure the draw immediately at
this in terms of position it's a very
simple draw after that but after 95 yeah
what I'm slightly afraid of this um oh
you're for the draw to draw our third
yeah why this of course just better I'd
really don't I mean I'm down I'm down
load time but the position is simply
better for why I'm warning it was nice
now i get to see Five now or this this
type of structure which is also quite
favorable ok ok I take that black resign
yeah very weird but i really i mean i'm
down on time but why should i take the
draw white is just better in the
position he's got decent drawing chances
but i've got i've got two bishops home
for nothing if he does not blunder this
is of course something to check um yeah
but where where's he supposed to go and
say he goes here oh this is in fact of
course totally winning yeah i get any i
have so much temper moves it is a loss
anyway he had this position he cannot do
anything against this and here i have i
have all those table moves so why this
white is completely winning yeah it was
it was quite strange that he allowed
this Bishop e7 but he was just playing
in cinemas all the time so no wonder
yeah this is this is helping me a great
deal as i get get in here yeah here King
c5 is also good I didn't have time
anymore to to look at this but this is
very strong actually I get they get the
whole crew inside while this is at the
moment
just a hemmed in by the you five and
therefore porn now no right here I mean
I don't sure this this really should be
something he needs to be very precise
and he very quickly accepted this type
of endgame which is just just not fun to
play at all Jack you know 8th was an
interesting that the computer suggests
but okay I don't think this was was
particularly bad as well yeah and now I
can just play as i did because you can
just continue with the two bishops these
kind of ideas can be can be in the
pollution so besides the time no reason
to take it raw alright thanks for
watching